foreign
distinguished dear guests
because they Allen I learned a lot
through the back and forth between you
and and prosecutive's questions and
comments I mean that thank you for
sharing so much knowledge you know it's
just amazing and I'm so glad thank you
Tom thank you Ben Causeway for recording
this you know this is um this is
historical even if this is historical
and and it does have the potential I
think to reach out to
to focus on both ends of the spectrum
both the naku and and the dragon Japan
though both the colonized and the
colonizer in many ways in a way that can
enrich all of us so thank you for that
so now we're going to hear
um teacher busal
introduced this beautiful chapter
powerful chapter of the power and beauty
of the Sovereign people and we go around
the room and ask questions thank you and
discuss and I'm really happy to behave
because they have been a real a context
well
you feel at home because everything you
have said up to now
even from the very beginning
give you the sense what is the colonial
reading the colonial study because it's
something that is that start with your
personal position you must know where
you are you might be aware of where you
are and from that you see the world
you know I mean because in fact this is
what what this is what is your power
the possibility of seeing the word from
your position not from the position they
have given you you find new position you
define new position and from new
position
you is seeing the word and something I
have written into my mind is fundamental
the use of social sciences the reason
that of social sciences is to regain to
give to those who have been dispossessed
to re-empower them if not I don't know
why they study you I'm not there to
empower those who are empowered you know
I have been disempowered and my
my a
IM is to study to work so I can regain
my position over myself over my people
for my people to move forward now this
implies understanding myself
understanding my people and
understanding the other and then I move
from there
so the beauty and power of the
Sovereign people is that
we come
from a set of individuals because
capitalism and the European capitalism
modern time capitalism
no is based on the disaggregation of the
communities
you take the communities you make of
them
naked individuals and then you give them
the possibility of rejoining within your
own Norms no quality Syndicate called
the Trade union whatever you want but
after you make of them
naked individuals okay we were taken
from Africa from in the case of Saint
domain
AG
at least 24 different nations
no they mix them all they mix us up in
the country and we are going to recreate
ourselves how do we that we do we do
that first of all we create
with nothing eh groups a social group
just to protect us because when you
reach there
as an enslaved person no they are going
to beat you to well to destroy you no
when you finish working the few times
they gave you to rest you will find
consolation you will find affection if I
love you will find reciprocity you will
find solidarity you give and takes you
will find human relations no so you will
create you recreate a social group you
mean this is this social group you will
create is going to have a set of
principles a set of norms no and these
Norms going to give way to a new
individual you're going to create a new
individual according to your own Norm to
your own principle
and it is that new individuals that will
be a poor in front of the other power so
that gives you the possibility of
discovering out of nothing no you're
going to imagine another poor and it is
so
important that the one who brought you
in the cabin or in the plantation system
to exploit you is going to spend all his
efforts to destroy you because you have
something and you're going to be aware
of that something for instance
they will say Voodoo or whatever we do
or be or whatever it is is superstition
or
also position is useless let me use it
it's not doing anything it has no
solution why do you make so much effort
to destroy it I mean so therefore you
are acknowledging that no another
element that is important also
gwende you want me to do that I don't do
it you beat me up you can't even kill me
so I can do it but I never see you
killing a donkey because it doesn't work
it doesn't want to drink water
because you know the donkey is an animal
you know I mean so they you know but me
you're going to beat me until I'm dead
therefore you acknowledge I'm equal
equal to you
no no you beat me because you know I
have a will and this will escape to you
Escape you know and this is my power
okay with that power in front of you
might because you really have a might no
I am going now to create
myself being my sovereignty you know
with nothing no I'm going to recreate a
new society that is the beauty of it and
this is what we have to be aware of it
oh well now
it is not that I feel strong no no no no
no I am going to create the whole set of
institutions
you said I mean a language a religion a
Villages a set of Institutions that I
create to take care of myself and to
reproduce myself and also to have
accountability for the members of of the
group you said I mean so I create an
Another Universe in front of your
Universe no and your Universe since you
despise me
cannot seek me
yeah I mean even when they see me they
said they are stupid thing [ __ ] are
doing you see what I mean even when they
see it they cannot adjust it so
therefore myself
to survive I first learn what you have
in mind and I in group though I'm going
to imagine how to bypass what you have
in mind to the small possibilities
sometimes I can't sometimes I can but I
will never lose the opportunity of doing
that this is
therefore some people coming down here
or brought down here against their will
after much suffering eh because you do
not leave Africa as a tourist now you
are beaten and you have to work sometime
hundreds and hundreds of miles they put
you in circumstances you have never
imagined they put you on the body
situation I said why you come here and
when you come here now they start
humiliating you doing thing that uh
Beyond imagination no they sell you they
stamp you Etc I will not describe all
the things but in that I would say
infinite
poverty you know and destruction you go
you're going to Reborn
this is the beauty of the Sovereign
people now how do you do that I say you
create a community but the community you
created in the plantation itself
I mean while you're working on the
plantation
no you're creating social groups in
spite of the intention of the person to
call you black black is a colonial word
in Africa you're not black you can be
Ashanti you can be Nago you can't be
Igbo you can be anything but black
because everybody is black so black do
not distinguish one to another you see I
mean yeah so you come here
no and you create a little group on the
plantation
now in that group there are that really
cannot survive in the plantation they
will run away and you'll have a set of
Bandits and people
slowly living out of
stealing Goods coming in and out looking
for weapons he said I said yeah they are
a set of generally male Maroons no those
meal Maroons and you you are in contact
no and at some point in time they will
with their ladies go and create the
privilege system
you say I mean now from the people on
the plantation the independent Fighters
or Brigade or whatever they call them to
the Village system you have a constant
movement of ideas and flows of going on
and this is done through the language
you know I mean through the language so
you have now a whole in the plantation
system before independence you have a
whole movement
of concept of habits of conducts no that
teach you the possibility of bypassing
the system defending yourself against
the system now this is possible
particularly in the large Antilles or in
Suriname or in the the guyanas no
and this give you no what I call the
counter plantation system
which is the basis the basis for the
nation
not yet the nation is being born but I
mean the Haitians or the Jamaicans is
situation this is one line of the
development in the case for instance of
the small island like Saint Vincent
Barbados Martinique they have to
negotiate within the system
take Bobby this is the best example
because they were the seat of the of the
royal Navy so you better behave yourself
for the kingdom that's all you said I
mean so you have to learn to negotiate
within their system no but this is the
basic the same basic
a position I mean they are different
because the condition in which they are
negotiating are not the condition in
which for instance the Suriname is is
negotiating and assuming is that the
American who will show them how the
Amazonian etc etc now they are in any
event
this is what we are doing we prepare
ourselves in the negotiation we create a
group of people you know who can
see another reality create another
universe and a universe that the
powerful so-called no tend to erase no
and we confront those two universes
now when
the Imperial con Imperial Colonial
countries
enter in conflicts no they create a
possibility for you to break in you said
I mean so there is no difference between
a Haitian and the Jamaican except what I
told you so what happened outside there
is no difference between the Haitian or
Jamaican and rubber region except that
one is in a small island which is
Barbados is something like 300 times
smaller than the whole island Dr and
Haiti because we have an island in front
of our Prince Laguna no which is twice
bigger than Barbados and Island only the
country is something 70 times if you put
the idea so you can imagine the
possibility of negotiation in this
island and those of the buildings are
quite different you know not to speak of
the condition in which Barbados was
settled no Barbados was settled by
couples
by British who came with their wives you
said I mean so that one thing they do
they do not have a lot of the people of
koala they use Nana they have but they
do not have a lot that's one condition
but we are all in fact the basic
a set of position of respectful
self-respect sovereignty group
autonomy this is what is our base so
Beauty the beauty is that in the worst
condition of living thing we could not
possibly imagine that is happening I do
not want to enter in the relationship
between the the white males and they are
enslaved and their kids and their
daughters what they have no no no we can
just imagine not that they are they are
they think they are all powerful they do
whatever they want they destroy
themselves but that's another problem
but forget about that we simply create
our world out of nothing in this
Caribbean word no when I say out of
nothing
we do have a
resources we remember from Africa but
they are individuals who remember that
we have an advantage though
over the first nations in America the
First Nations all the Jews also they are
people that were exploited
but they were a nation that were
exploited
you see I mean they have been forced to
witness the destruction of their Nation
you see the Mayas the Aztec or the Incas
they can see the spaniel coming and they
have lived that in our case no for
instance assuming that they get into
Yoruba country or Igbo country the the
they beat them and they take you and
they bring you here you would say oh
okay I lost I was that's bad luck they
got me but the country nobody can beat
the evils even if it is not true but you
will imagine that you you have not
witnessed you Society being humiliated
you Kings being a
yes humiliated
Etc so we have at least that we start
with a local experience from the day we
came here in America no and from that
local elections we move forward so we
can create a new Society a new world
with our experience not with
we do not carry all the tradition of our
society no and we do not carry the the
day the sorrow
of foreign
or Bolivia where they are playing the
the conquest
I mean the Americans are playing the
conquest you said I mean you can see all
the sadness
in the winning of the the of the alien
over you know we don't have that
possibility no and in general our
musical production is quite different
from theirs so this is what I call the
beauty and of of the our nation what we
are we have witnessed what we have
created the problem is that we have to
make our people aware of that and this
is what the system and what the
professor the graph was showing wants
you not to see
you see a for instance the beauty of
Creole Creole is switching the meaning
of key function
one of my great friends and professor
gear movementfield from Mexico he say
Indian Negroes or Colonial concept
there were no Indian in America before
Christopher Columbus made these mistakes
no Negroes that you call [ __ ] may I
don't know if I am a negro I mean that's
meaningless that I am a negro easy
dressy dress those are key concepts of
colonialism they create race a set of
languages in Africa has no word for it
and in Haiti risks mean family according
to all French no
as is the race of the risk of Kazi music
watch out with the rest of what you
guessing they are really bad people all
of them they are witches you know I mean
I mean but they mean the family not the
race what the West Conference so we came
and we create another concept and as the
I don't know if you know but as
everybody knows and I give the example
so many times why is do not mean what it
means in French or in English
White
for instance I have a very good friend
of mine from Jamaica I see when I do
something in my computer I say I trick
the white man but I don't mean white men
women who is white I mean I took the
technology the dominant one the one who
want
the algorithm to work that way I will
make it work another way you know I mean
this is what called the white man and in
fact in my proposition white means in
Haiti the responsible of the Primitive
accumulation of capital
we need to be the dominant capitalist
field who came and take whatever he sees
that he is and he take it if he wants it
period now he has been that's why so any
for instance if he comes home they'll
say there's a negro asking for you yeah
that's right that's right so if Tom goes
to Haiti Tom becomes a negro because
negro means human being period and
reverse the reverse is true too my
daughter is like you all my son also and
they are all white because they are
strangers they can't speak we all they
don't know the habits you know the
habits they have to you know I mean that
it's not discriminatory it's just simply
they they do not know what's going on
they do not know the rules of the game
no that's it so you have changed the key
concept of the of the dominant system
and you have created your world well
everybody is a person you have created
the word Moon
you know I mean the word moon has
nothing to do with white black male
female just mean person every person is
a person it should be respected as such
you know I mean this is something you
have done when you are in the tree form
in the depth of misery
you know to get out and to create that
group to that can survive oppression no
you have to erase that this is why the
evil disappeared the Congo disappeared
the outside disappeared no you become a
moon no and you have to be in as far as
I know in Haiti the worst of all sin is
to destroy life
you have to respect life period you're
not eager to three for nothing you don't
kill
[Music]
an insect for nothing no no no no no no
no that is a sin this is what is a sin
so
the beauty
of The Sovereign people is that it has
been able to invent his sovereignty
you send me an event itself as distinct
from and this is where also he has been
able to show you
make you see what power means in fact
poor does it mean that you're stronger
you have more strength no no no that is
not really poor this is apparents of
power because your strengths you have it
because I am powerful
you see I like to tell my friend
he well in fact that's an idea that is
in Eric Williams he did develop now
let's see the Haitians to beat the
Haitian Napoleon send 40 000 persons and
they lost so he was Stronger 40 000 plus
one
at least you know because we they lost
hope so if you want to know what power
is ask us because we beat him
he said I mean you must understand what
PO is obviously in Haiti they are
destroying the use of Creole they do not
want Creole as you have seen no because
Quail is powerful
that you must be aware of this power
that you control you manage and you are
the one who invented when I say
something in French the French Academy
will decide or in Spanish the Royal
Academy the Academia will decide if it
is correct if you can say it okay if you
cannot say it if I'm talking Jamaican
that the French town that will decide if
this can be said or not it's not the
government not even the government It Is
Us us in our most in existence without
Authority it is the agreement between us
that we decide that what is for instance
a shackle shacking up
if this is a acceptable or not it is not
an authority it is the consensus between
the few people this is what sovereignty
is so I will stop there
oh boy
you know what you said about
um white reminds me of James Baldwin yes
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly for power
there's no such thing as whiteness um
white is just Manhattan Bank yeah
exactly yeah yeah yeah so thank you
thank you for this you know amazing
summary of your entire approach really
to Haitian history yeah so all right so
it's a lot like the the white thing for
me I hear it as the
it's a political position sort of of
your relationality to the world to
things to land to food to people
um rather than the color of your skin
your mental state of how you see the
world
okay so you get to go around the room
and ask questions so that actually can
be at the end of very quickly I think I
think they're releasing you okay all
right what was interesting thing that
stood out to me in the reading was
cultural homogenization and how come
again cultural homogenization cultural
imagination homogenization
of how like Customs habits and
aspirations were not pursued by the
racist and eurocentric public
authorities but rather Productions
carried out by the sufferers
oh by the suffers and I thought that was
it was super interesting to think of it
that way because I'd personally always
thought of like oh they classify us like
we're classified as black because
there's a racist system that sees us all
as like just one person and not like
different Ambitions but I never thought
of it as like a positive light like how
you spun it how it wasn't it was an
aspect of our survival we had to unify
under this one formed culture
um and I actually thought that was
interesting and I was wondering
um how did you get to that point of
realizing that we formed this one
homogenized culture not
out of um just simply out of spite in
some cases out of survival and out of
spite
how did you get to this point I see you
point a to me I think now you make me
see that I think I should go back to my
friend I just mentioned game open field
Guillermo
an anthropologist
he said
Indian is an invention of the Spaniards
when you take an Inuit
[Music]
what do you mean why you want them to be
Hindus I mean they I mean what is what
does somebody who live his life in snow
has to do with it
to be a Seminole whatever it is because
you want them to work a new homogenize
them in your imagination to make to work
and to exploit them the way you want you
invent that life okay so this is one
thing he put and I start saying
that therefore is a colonial concept
white is a colonial concept how
does the Haitian call himself
no and I found in that book of devotee
our first Haitian historian no he he
called the book A the colonial system
unveiled it is in English it's 90
pictures the book has no and I realized
in these 90 pictures devati used 100
times the word mollywood
in Malawi can be a rich man or a woman
it means you fragile you are alone
you are vulnerable no so even if you
reach to that figure malaria because you
can't come fell down and break your leg
you know I mean not only that the
importance of the malaria is that I was
in Africa going to picnic with my
girlfriend and all of a sudden came from
Bandits for no reason they picked me up
and here I am my girlfriend in Saint
Vincent as a slave me in Cuba as another
slave no we have done nothing to deserve
that a
so that Destiny no
we are the Mali no and up to now today
the Haitian defined himself as maliri
and this is why my great friend and
translator
take from Bob Marley the word sufferer
we are sufferers it is not that we are a
politician who came from and we could
move through a social Mobility outside
of the politayat we do not have a common
history with the murwazi the Bourgeois
and the politeria in Europe come from
the booth of the city and they fought
together
he for instance against the nobility and
the clergy and after the French
revolutions they split when capitalism
start moving but they have the same
history they have the same language they
have the same religion they have a whole
hundreds of you know that's not my case
I just took they put together in front
of that tape
because I have done nothing to deserve
that those
suffering things that happened so when I
find the word surprise oh boy that's it
and this is the queer who gave it to me
maliwi I I Haitian do not say um
and you can call anybody that will be
Malaysia
look at that poolage
you know I mean full stop but that has
nothing to do okay that means also if I
get out of the Malayalam of that misery
which is not something that came from my
Willow from my effort it's an accident I
an accident put me in it an accident
will take me out of it
my mother and my father could work their
life they will not make a new professor
is one day and accident a friend of mine
was minister of their world Minister
what they found a scholarship and I get
out of it you know I mean obviously I'm
not going to lose but the fact of the
matter matter is you don't get out of it
you don't get into it because you're
poor you don't get out of it because you
work
therefore
you should respect all of the Maliki
so the respect
you know I mean it's basic all over in
Jamaica when I was there no this they
agreed to respect that the greeting I
mean respect that's the greeting because
I may be very rich I may be very poor
but I earned the same respect you said I
mean so this is how I would say I think
I get to the word malery
suffer right because it's just in our
language so
to my mind for social scientists now you
should be aware and know and study your
language if you have an hypothesis you
cannot put it in your own local language
those of us who have two languages you
said I mean he's not he's not working it
has to be a translatable to our language
because we're working in if we work
directly in local in our language
obviously that come out like I don't
know if I answer your questions
yeah
so are you going to speak to you back on
yeah yeah
no just the concept of
um of being a malibrium
um
you need to think about like The Wider
idea of uh even like the rational uh
movement of like thinking that we are
powerful which is the concept of
capitalism that we are so powerful you
work hard yeah somewhere but you know
most people who work really really hard
are still malaria yeah
so but it kind of for me brings the
question that I like to maybe hear your
thoughts on is the idea of poverty what
is poverty if poverty is still a
definition based on acquiring property
it's even like the relationship to to
also relation to land like if you're
rich if you own land rather than if you
have relationship to end and also the
idea that we come in and out of
circumstances Often by influences that
are outside of our own doing like I was
going on a picnic with my girlfriend and
suddenly I'm an enslaved person in Cuba
like this was not my own doing no no
um which is in
specifically antithesis of the whole
capitalist approach everything is your
own doing which doesn't humble itself to
other
I I don't I'm just bringing it up to say
you know how how do we
provide a different Paradigm or
perspective to look at what is poverty
and what is The Human Condition really
in terms of
you know the arrogance of capitalism
which continues to destroy our countries
today like it is the like Haiti today is
destroyed by the poorest country ever I
think
this is where I find the importance of
the decolonial studies because you
should see capitalism from your anger
with all due respect for the capital is
there a set of liars
I'm going to tell you why they declared
private property is sacred
no they came here in America they took
everything that they they they can't see
they took it literally no in Haiti they
call they took sandoman and the king of
Saint domain of Spain will give the
third of Saint domain to a the French
and they declare to me private property
is is sacred was it was who gave them
same domain how could they take it for
themselves you said I mean use the
Seminole and this thing presented by
by Peck no it's I mean you come there
you take my land and you take that man
and you're telling me it's used how do
you manage I don't know if you see that
the documentary of Raul pick only
um
examine exterminate all the brutes you
know I mean the blues come they take the
country
no they take over the country they take
all the weight when they finish with the
oils in the Caribbean they go in Mexico
they go in Period they take everything
they had no and they start their
capitalism you know I mean they start
developing and they're telling me
private property is sacred that we have
to respect that
how come if you start lying if you seize
what is not used
no but you declare that God give me half
of this who's God use your mind
what do you have to see with that you
see so the question of poverty you
impoverished me because you define
wealth the way you want you take it and
you say I have to respect it
no and you have a set of Institutions
School Etc to prove to me that I deserve
to be proof improved for instance I am
black I'm this one of harm God sort of
sort of real really lies you said I mean
not only that he
this question of there is a verse I
don't have it in mind but that is good
well in The Exodus no it said if you
take a person you sell the person you
deserve a death
you know what I mean but on the other
hand they're going to say the son of
Harm's world
so they are a set of liars and I do not
have to believe that and I do not have
to respect that no and studies made
will show that I mean I'm talking about
magic whenever
historian who was member of the Legacy
for the whole 19th century he said the
sea the system is corrupt because
corruption made the colonial system
so you cannot expect today the the
authorities of Haiti not to be correct a
corrupt no same thing in the U.S the
system is based on corruption how could
you take the land of the Indians to go
and kill Indians you know I mean and now
you make them pull you create them you
create their poverty not only equate
their poverty you start ruling them with
English when they are they were being
ruled they had a situated so I think
poverty and wealth and this is why also
we must be aware of what we call what
what is what allows us to survive to be
to exist this is where imagination
become invention come
all non-material
knowledge will come I'm not a
belittling technology because you have
done something with the ways you have
taken and I want to
I respect that no but this is your
interest now my job is with my
imagination to have to use you
technology
to first to empower my people
you see what I mean
I mean this is how more or less I see it
no Haiti is the poorest country in the
world according to the is the
establishments set a
views but as I told you Lord best this
famous economies from Trinidad say it is
the richest country in the in America
according to Lloyd best no and he said
he he wrote a long article on that I
could look for it no but to show you
that you have a police
it's not that we we we like poverty we
like whatever you know I mean no noise
that's not the point the point is that
you respect yourself you like yourself
you protect yourself and listen is quite
quite clear also also on that you know I
mean this is the and you must be aware
of that this is the problem don't let
people divert your attention towards
those material materials it is important
I have to drink water and clean water I
cannot you know I mean do without it no
but it is not that that made me as we
say in Haiti you're not going to have
that to the gradient to the graveyard
with you you're going to go to the
graveyard naked okay
let's go around to it let's fit write
down your question and then yeah
a little mask oh I have like four
questions until one but like they all
centered on the contrabandation system
around the counter plantations yeah so
do you think that
this was you know a master away from
home health cultivate the counter
plantation system and like you know
coming from like a Dominican person like
someone who was governed by Spain do you
think this is also why Haiti was able to
be successful in this system meanwhile
the Dr we still have like asean Das and
you know modern plantations and thinking
about success how successful was the
consultation system and like are we
mastering success on the basis of do our
people remembered or are people
knowledgeable or are we mentioning on a
have we managed like dismantle the
capitalist society that the Antilles was
built upon and we do to answer the first
half and then you re you reformulate the
second half
the Hacienda could be the proper
translation for the word Plantation
so the French never heard the
counterpradition system the French has
an Hacienda no it organized Diaz and
that properly as a capitalist system a
rational system where every single input
no
oriented toward an output called a
merchandise a commodity to produce more
Commodities that is the plantation the
Hacienda now to save some money now the
owner of the Hacienda of the plantation
have some what we call provision grounds
I mean where they won't pay you they
have you working on the konoku it's okay
now you on the konoku on the provision
grounds you're going to organize
the yard you're going to organize a
system of solidarity and reciprocity
where you protect your people so you're
making use of one move of the dominant
system no for your own ends you we call
that you serve
you
utilize the dominant system to serve
your own ends so therefore the counter
plantation system no is born within the
plantation system within the Hacienda
and when 1791 let's say 117 seconds 17
minutes 89 when the French Revolution
started and the Planters the ascendiro
start fighting each other no you start
developing yukonucos
no and this is when the next one is
going really to take its structure but
on a national level no and since I am
there
what is important is that the counter
plantation system The Villages it's a
village system
no the villagers are isolated
no they are micro climates they produce
certain Goods if you're in the mountain
you can have spices you can have fruits
Etc if you're the throttle and you have
mango you have banana you sit you are in
the mountain you have coffee so you have
to exchange no and you are going to
create this is a case the internal
Market because there was no internal
market in terms of in colonial time what
was important was only the export of the
commodity so you create the counter
plant differences you create the
internal market and who manage internal
Market
the female higlas
the woman was going to tide up the
nation the women tired of the nation not
the men the men can work whatever it is
but those who are responsible to moving
goods and moving money are female up to
now
you know I mean your parents when they
send money home they didn't send it to
any man they send it to a woman
because she managed money she managed
resources no so she will be the one who
will
tied up what I call the 12 the three
pillars of the nation community
internal market and women but what tied
them up to your language
you said I mean you don't see a
heagler-speaking standard neglects
English speak rough Jamaican English you
know I mean and this is what is
sustained the nation on top of that then
oligarchy is going to okay now give me
the second part of your question
especially it's just like I mean
you can have success
system and are we mentioning success on
the basis of like do our people remember
their you know their history are they
knowledgeable or are we measuring on a
have we managed to dismantle like the
capitalistic society that was
established in the penalty until the
sport Haiti wonderful the Contra
plantation system
explain the whole 19th century age
no how we might we can measure his
his success we started independence with
maximum 350 000 people
we ended up the 19th century with two
million people
you know I mean we multiplied but this
is not codified by the government we're
going to want to recreate the plantation
what do we create haciendas now they
will not talk about that but the fact of
the matter is we did that not only did
we did we do that
no we I mean the the Haitians real I
call them Asian Guinea and Haitians no
the Haitian
real Haitians no start absorbing the
oligarchy
no because the oligashi has no use for
French because they had no relational
religion so they start speaking we all
this and they had no it is in until 1860
that the the Catholic Church
acknowledged the existence of which
instead sending prison 12 or 50 whatever
it is so the people have to use in the
spirit spirituality of obia or Voodoo
you see I mean so this are being
absorbed by now what make that possible
it's not that we are so special now at
that time the big empires of the West
were entering in the Imperial Colonial
time they are conquering Africa
Conquering the salty City so they could
do the kaiban economy becomes totally
secondary and you had big sugar etc etc
you said I mean so they forget about us
thanks God so we could develop
you see so for instance if you take the
case of let's say to come back to
Bobby's boy good thing there is no
virgin hey you will challenge me stop
thinking about Barbados but in Barbados
for instance the Planters had a hole on
the land
in the production of sugarcane after
emancipation was higher than before
to tell you the level of exploitation of
the pigeons to such an extent they were
so attacked by hunger that this third
magnet to Guyana and then to
build the Panama Canal same thing with
Martinique were the
Planters could have a hold on the land
so they they had to migrate outside no
not only that the migration to the
Panama Canal to the oil field of
Venezuela is I was such that some
countries in the Caribbean had no more
men
do you have only male a old male kids
and a set of an equilibrium and point
that out homosexuality start developing
to such a Nixon for instance in in Saint
Lucia the word zami friend mean lesbian
no I I was making studies in Creole no
in Twin Creole to indigen and I said
also and so is my zami my friend and the
central can say you don't say that you
can't he can't be your friend I said why
French mean lesbian because the world
become normal and it's not that lesbian
reasons you
to the to the face or to diminish no no
no no that's normal the two ladies live
together they are zombies you I mean
that was normal because there was no
male figure adult male in civil and Eric
Williams even mentioned that in some
Caribbean islands that regret I mean
their population start diminishing
you see I mean in the case of Jamaica
this is the moment of the migration
toward Costa Rica toward the movement of
Marcus Garvey you know I mean because
there is no way
you can attack the land
of the British owners in the case of
Haiti we didn't go frontally toward the
land property no
we start occupying it and the state
didn't have strength enough to kick us
out of the lead no
there are several elements there I could
I could well in the Dr I think something
like that happened because Plantation
really started with to heal you know I
mean the American came and and it they
needed to hear to to help them and you
had land
no not only that the Dominican Republic
I think developed a set of cattle
raising to to complete to serve the part
of colonial French plantation system now
they will sell cattles no so there's a
whole tradition of cattle raising and
when Haitians start their migration they
start since they were basically
agriculturalists no you say peasants
they start planting and this annoyed to
heal because anything he made to occupy
this land if he gave land the Dominicans
go toward cattle racing and the one who
are taking profit of the land given was
Haitian origin people that was their
tradition they situated that creates
certain conflicts with the state because
the capital as they say the Wizards
eastern part of the country not the
central part of the country and
incidentally I don't know if you know
that most of our
the heroes of this period were from not
if not from the Dominica from the border
hash this lascau bus this part in
between the two countries now this is
where we had mostly
strongest opponent to the U.S occupation
yes indeed shall my period the name is
Peralta in fact not you know what I mean
we say Pirate no but he's Peralta you
know a city or a city
did I answer your second question
okay I had two questions
um one of them was based on the console
partition system
I had two questions
um one of them is based on the counter
plantation system but my question was
would you say that the counter
plantation system was an idea given to
the uh enslaved by the colonizers given
that they because I know
um in history books they tell you that
the colonizers made the enslaved found
their own food to sustain themselves so
I was wondering like is that do you
think that's an idea that they were
given in a sense or was that just
by products
that's one that's one question our
second question is
um while I was reading the chapter I
remember the podcast I was listening to
and one of the um one of the guests was
saying that they believed that Haiti
should have waited
um before the diet should not have done
the revolution revolution when they did
it we were too early right so my
question my question is what do you
think about that because in my opinion I
could see if they had waited it would
change like the trajectory of the slave
the slave revolutions that came after
but I just wanted to know what you
thought about that okay too early listen
first of all
the the counter plantation system I call
it counterproduction system because it's
not a classical presently
simply for that because the classical
presenter is auto self-sufficient if you
take for instance mesoamerica or even
Central Europe no The Peasants produce
even the instrument of production of the
yes incident opportunity
okay not only that they have even their
textile there is no more sophisticated
textile than the guatemalian textile you
know I mean they they weave their thing
in something great but if you are an
enslaved there's a certain number of
things you cannot produce yourself don't
like the button a
instrument
ity because you don't have any while the
Africans were very skillful in in
dealing with the with iron but in the
Caribbean were you going to find iron so
you have a peasant wind quote that must
produce an excess to exchange for the
other good so it's not exactly a present
it's why I call it the counter
plantation system now I don't think the
system comes from the that has nothing
to do with the plotters because the
planter cannot imagine a type of of
relation family relation like we have
first of all to understand really our
family we must take into account the
fact that the slave has no gender
you mean they have sex but no gender I
mean like a cattle have no gender no so
the first creation of the contemplating
system will be the invention of women we
create our women we create our agenda we
create our men we have to imagine a form
of stroke of structure where that female
and that male can function it did not
function under slavery it functions in
the counter plantation system no now we
create also the form of a pairing well
yes you know the form of because
do we have
a mono by I don't know monopolitan
monogamy do we have polygamy do we have
I mean that's up to now we cannot solve
that question let me tell you
know I want to for instance I was
telling my my wife my companion
that the young lady working by me is
telling that so and so of his friend is
not there because the husband went to
visit
he's married woman
no so her friend
you know is not is available she can
visit her friend because the husband of
her friend go to see her married woman
so I tell my wife is I say you my
married woman what would you say I think
yeah
because the fact of assuming
that the companion has a married woman
mean that they are polygam
and he's not she doesn't feel any bad
about that she's living in polygamy and
the first lady who married the man is
the married woman and she's also the
woman and for the married women don't
don't you believe that this means
for the ladies that means no no that
means the fellow is not there all the
time to bother them period they can do
their thing they organize their life you
know I mean simply and they have some
sexual sexual partner when they need or
if they arrange themselves it's a
different set
conception of family you said I mean not
only that when you have a quarrel you
have a conflicts no the lady who is the
weakest person in the couple
he she is not going toward the husband
to help her she go towards the Elder's
brother
you know I mean it she looked in her
family who will protect her not in the
family of the of the husband she may but
that's not necessary
that the husband
I mean sorry the head of the family of
her family
the eldest brother or whoever is the
head must come out
if they hope and come that will help
that that's not the point see go to the
so we have another concept organization
which is not codified because we are so
brainwashed by the Catholic Church we're
looking for a for a couples all over and
we're seeing the men are so promiscuous
they don't take care of their kids it's
not the father
well I won't give more more anecdote I
was going to give you another one please
okay the other one is the following I
was teaching in Congo with my
wife we were both teachers no and one of
the he said that my wife received said
my eldest father was sleeping under the
tree
my wife said what's that so we had to
Congolese living with us he said listen
no what is an eldest father he has a
youngest one as the Congolese start
laughing like hell he takes five minutes
before he answered so yes because the
word for father is the same for Uncle
that means the eldest brother of his
mother you know I mean so he's as a
father and in Haiti everybody call me
father
when I go southern Mexico they call me
abuelo grandfather you know I mean
everybody called me Abuelo and Miami let
me do that in Haiti father to such an
extent the police stopped me and say
father he give me your license I say I'm
just a minute my son
how come you called me son I said but
you just called me Father
you see I mean these these uh
definitions that are contextual and and
we use it but this is not codified and
they still do not want to hear from that
because they said have to be at par with
the International Community
you see I mean and there is no way you
make them respect that and I give the
story to boys on the graph of that
friend of mine who is member of the
Great Commission of Human Rights now
when we say they should make laws for
the people who suck up
he told me shacking up cannot be object
of law because it is a crime
you I mean you can imagine a lawyer
saying that
human rights somebody of my you know a
little bit younger than me I mean but
this is what he receive at school
I'm also talking about the difference
between citizenship being a citizen
which is what the state wants us to be
it's
yeah and then being a people of a laku
or a community yes exactly uh of like
calling you father none calling you
citizen
citizen in our case in our tradition is
the land owner who has a certain number
of enslaver those are active citizens
and the others are passives
that's like what we're all being pushed
to become less of Community people and
more of citizens no but the people do
not want to be citizen either they do
not want the state the state never did
anything for them since they exist they
start existing I mean they don't want to
about this I mean I hope so but I mean
more people want to be citizens of the
problem
in the world I think no no I'm talking
about local local history but I find the
one I don't know there is a question
that Vienna asked about was it too early
oh yeah that's a very important question
okay
first of all at least in sociology you
don't decide what's going to happen
Society moves no and we had an
opportunity we went through we did we
were not asked to do for instance do
what they speak of the Haitians in spite
of the frustration
not talking about the set of the
freedmen a emancipated person who wanted
to go and to be French and who actually
maintained France of French up to now as
the key of Haiti but Napoleon has
decided to kill them and to or to deport
them you know so they had to fight with
the Maroons for Independence no so he
called them
the Haitian in spite of themselves
falseation and those Haitians were very
important in the fight for independence
together with the Marines if not we will
have a [ __ ] society and Muslim rules
like in Suriname and then they would
conquer us again no they so they were
important nonetheless
they didn't choose to fight France
France first had to fight them that's
one aspect second aspect which is very
very very important when most people are
saying heiji is independent was
independent too soon and not anybody
said that I'm talking about ABC's here
I'm talking about
you know I mean I mean people will say
how could hey it is so rich he's so poor
now that's not possible they have been
independent too much you know well okay
I'm not saying what is the level of
living in the other countries of the
Caribbean because I can say the same
thing for the U.S I don't think the U.S
is that good either but okay I went to
whatever they want I grant them that but
what they do not take into account is
the fact that the Haitians by being
independent in 1804
protected the Haitian from death let me
tell you the circumstances
by
1803 or two or one but anyway
before in Haiti become Independence
Napoleon gave the order to kill all the
blacks who were Rebel and to re-people
the islands but he didn't give the order
he started
implementing this order in Guadalupe by
General response he started killing
blacks
killing them and Guadalupe who had
started the revolution when they
realized they are dying no they decided
okay let's try to live another day so we
will fight tomorrow no and they stop
fighting in this surrender and they were
re-enslaved not because we were fighting
against re-enslavement okay when they
stopped fighting they found that 10
percent of them were already killed you
see I mean so they were all about to
kill them in the case of Haiti they
start the same thing
at such a point that the polls who he
had sent to fight us no they were pulled
they were peasants no realizing that
they said no way we're not participating
in killing civilians and kids we did
come here for that and the move and
fight with the Haitians and this is also
another reason why this will indicate
that the pools were black because this
is what we call Black it's not being
black tainted okay so Haiti become
independent and Napoleon could not kill
those education to have two people they
said in the countries that remain
colonies no that were not independent so
soon no as I just told you you had a
letter or set of out migration because
you had hungers in Martinique hungers in
Barbados hungers in great hungers
because the white people Barbados is a
typical case intensified the
exploitation of their former enslaved no
and produce much more without
introducing new technology
you see Barbados was producing modern
Cuba no when Cuba had production with
new technology
so they increase
the exploitation of the bridges and more
bedroom die in Barbados and more bridges
have to leave the country in conditions
that were very similar to the slave
trade
you see what I mean so it is you didn't
choose to be independent the opportunity
come there is a crack in the system when
you move
no and you establish yourself you say no
but how did you done that what would
happen you know I mean because
now
that give us one way out Haitians become
independent we are we multiply the
population
etc etc etc but our development is based
on in management of our inner
system no while we do not have one thing
the virgins have or the Jamaicans also
they know how to negotiate with the
other person we don't know that up to
now
it is now that we are learning
what happened with the West you know
when the American occupied Haiti the
president of Egypt
had no idea of what the American were up
to he thought they came to help us he
could not imagine he came to exploit us
you can imagine a fellow president of
the Republic has no idea of the
equipment not only that the other day
when the U.S no the U.N head of mission
visited
we had visited the General headquarters
of the army no in the General
headquarters of the army all the big
Chiefs of the U.S occupation was there
as founder of the Haitian army he said
where have you found an independent
country where the occupant is put as the
creator of the army of the national Army
you can imagine Jamaica's a
headquarters of the army with all the
British there who created the Army for
God's sake at least take them off you
know I mean but in Haiti up to now and
they had that no not up to now because
I've seen end of this Army now but to
tell you not in the situation so is hate
independent too early or not okay I
don't know ask as what I would say as
those who died
you know I mean on the boat going and
the life of the Caribbean people in
Panama during the construction of the
like there's a wonderful documentary
he made here in the U.S on the Caribbean
people building the Panama Canal oh boy
you were to cry
you want to go in and up to now or they
are protesting you know I mean the way
they pay them the way they treat them
how they die I mean in Culebra no
building the Panama Canal because you
should not remain forget that the 19th
century is the time of Jim Crow laws
here and those who are construct
building the canal they are the Jim Crow
fellas you see what I mean I mean we
just have when the Black North American
when African-Americans start voting to
give you an idea what happened 50 years
earlier in countries that were not even
America
you say I mean this is how you know you
can imagine what was going on there no
so was Haiti to Independent too early
you know I mean are we comparing
what is left of Barbados because we let
a set of Barbadian died because this is
what happened Barbados is the country
Indica at least compared to Haiti well
even everybody has Secondary School you
diploma everybody everybody in Haiti
would not I think we click on them with
your hand and those who have it we don't
know how how bad is that the instruction
in education schooling is you said I
mean so obviously
this allows certain Visions to go
forward but how many of them died
how many of them are not there
you said I mean obviously I'm not I'm
sure that the state will not speak too
much about
this the suffering Martinique news new
Hunger while Haiti was at a time in what
money got called one of a historian
called lubunovir The Village happiness
you know I mean we had full-fledged
Village happiness no and the knowledge
without the state building one Hospital
because the knowledge of the people
which was not too much you could go
first but anyway that was enough to
multiply the population by five and not
only that there is no country in the
whole America
where you have a normal increase of the
population naturalities of the
population all of them increase their
population through migration coming from
Europe
and at this 19th century when they were
migrating
Latin America or South Africa etc etc I
want to know why they were leaving their
country not because they have too much
why the Italians left Italy what the
Spaniard left spin the vasque city why
the Dutch and the the the British left
in the 19th century when the when the
Industrial Revolution is taking place
when you have capitalism developing
itself and conquering the whole world
what was the level of living the number
of Swedish people who went from Sweden
to the US
no and you can see their photo when this
showing their migrants killing Indians
okay but listen if you are so well fed
in in
sweet sweet you're not coming here to
kill in Sweden to kill Indians stay home
you know I mean so all the things they
are not spoken this is not spoken and in
that time the Haitian will multiply
you know I mean this is another idea of
wealth to answer is what is wealth
my question
so
I I'll say like my general question and
then give a little bit of background as
to how I got there but if it seems very
general but my question is like what is
your why and the way I got to that was
like I think no you say what is you why
you're why like why
why you're doing this why you have this
like power and things like this
um the way I got to this question was I
think like every week we do readings we
come someone presents and while it is
based on the readings It's So based on
themselves as well and I like I feel
like I've learned so much about all the
people in this class and like what is
there why and like why they're here what
what they take from like every reading
and stuff like that so I wanted to know
like
specifically and personally what is your
my right yeah
you mean you mean let me tell you that's
a good question I love it yeah because
the colonial study implies that you
position yourself right seriously
absolutely absolutely it's too long so
you know I'm very old my wife
84 84. that's what I thought yeah
it's important to do when you were born
1938. first so
I belong to a generation
that come exactly after the war I am
born in 38 though there were the second
one was starting now and I start seeing
you know cons discovering reality after
the war in 1946 which is the time
exactly when we have what we call the
1946 Revolution
this 9646 this 1946 Revolution is the
consequence of the 1915 U.S occupation
when the U.S occupied Haiti the occupied
Haiti with two things the big stick in
one hand no and on the other hand their
gym Co policy so you can imagine they're
reintroducing Haiti
the whole color problem no this is when
price must come with the NC Palace
Etc and when you have the iniquity issue
being brewed in Europe and in Haiti and
you have juvali and what we call negris
no
going on not to answer the opposition
in the country where the Americans were
putting in large-skinned people all over
the situation
to give some background it was a scholar
who gave the idea that look we have to
go back to Africa to understand we as
Haitians so Africa is beautiful black is
beautiful and that was in a position to
the Americans that came in and that were
very racist so that's what is referring
to us yeah and interestingly enough
jumper smart is a big a son of big land
owners in the countryside like peralt
you know I mean because it's good to not
to put everybody in one bag now he is
latifu distance
he is proud of his position of his
what he is you know and he's a doctor
he's a diplomat so anyway so in 1946 end
of the war who is he was
President
israelisco no therefore the students
oh boy
okay the students
made a so-called Revolution and which
said Haiti is the back country the
president has to be black
it cannot be whatever it is but they use
the term black
which is a colonial concept no you know
I mean and you had as president a black
fellow you must say estimate who is a
big landowner also you said I mean so
you are going to have a possibility of
development
because that's the hippo when the U.S
come with the idea of development
a Truman when developmental they are
going to take a whole set of policies
toward development we have to develop
the country to make the country
capitalist mode and modernize the
country's situation so that the pure
when I am going to school
I mean during that period okay so to
jumping over 20 many things here I come
I found a scholarship
and I'm studying in Mexico so I want to
know why is it that we are supposed
after such a wonderful economy a
wonderful Evolution after such a
wonderful Independence how come weapon
no and I start studying that and I I
wrote my
license my
mind
this is my first level
not before master
y my personalities
on the Republic of Haiti where I went
through the history
tried to explain why we are the way we
are poor good and good because I am
searching for development
at the same time at the end of this
period
I entered the U.N and I ended up also in
the economic commission for Latin
America always after prohibition so on
after development let's develop the
country so I'm working on development to
find out that this is your law you know
I mean it's like the carrot you put in
front of the Donkey you know I mean you
can run you're going oh you're never
getting another
etc etc
in the process no I discover culture
I realized that Haitians from the very
beginning have two cultures and I wrote
my PhD thesis with the title The
oppressed culture
no I was studying in Mexico I was very
much influenced by the conception of the
Creole no so I call the dominant culture
well at that time Mexico was in the in
the process of
to teach Spanish to the First Nations
not because as far as the the ideology
was that would help them to develop now
they will modernize speaking Spanish and
because their language is not a language
it's kind of dialogue they're speaking
think that they are older than French
and Spanish but anyway so they want to
erase that to teach them to speak so
the Creole
Mexicans no
he they were the dominant class so the
dominant culture and H I call it the
Creole culture as opposed to a no press
culture which is the culture of the
of the peasants no and I entered into
the dichotomy between Creole and bosal
no the Haitian crew lies and the basal
just fresh from Africa and that give a
false idea of the process no but that's
not the point that give the basis for my
for my study on oppress culture and I
show how Africa was erased from the
history of Haiti because of the
dominance of the quills
and he also he well
I I
proposed
accultuation so the queers were those
who was acculturated who had learned the
the Western
the culture who are ruling the country
who are the Elite
etc etc you see what I went I mean while
the other one was speaking Creole the
language and they were the oppressed
culture they have all sort of other
institutions also over the system who
were traditional
backward I would probably not use
backwards no but they were traditional
they were not modern no and you had to
pull them out
of their traditionalism to modernize
them you know I mean more or less
well that was a let's see
one stage
and at the same time I'm discovering
that the UN has five or six decades the
world of development always coming back
to square one there was no development
but they were investing in decades of
development and I was working in that
following privilege at the same time I
had used and since
the theory of dependency I mean the
problem of development in Latin America
and the Caribbean is that we were
dependent of the large countries the
rich countries now and we should try to
have a set of the sector of our economy
that will pull through the sector I mean
this sector will control it through
through a national bourgeoisie you said
I mean this was very common in the 60s
to explain the situation and you try to
have an independent sector who will be
the the locomotive
you know to pull the the to pull the
train you know I mean etc etc but
obviously nobody never had it or those
who had it were co-opted no but this is
what
we were using
but I still keep it was quite
insatisfied because that will not take
Haiti out of poverty and not only that
that implies
as a dictator the son of Diwali Etc an
effort by the U.S to a institutional
industrialize the country Etc all
coming always back to this poverty he
said I mean so this is when I start I
first of all I move out of the idea of
development realizing that development
is not bringing us anywhere
no
and therefore
what
in the process of studying the oppressed
culture
I
found the counterplantation system I
found the village society and I was by
that time working in Trinidad with my
Caribbean friends I started realizing
that Plantation because we are talking
development is the
locomotive not the the key part of the
Train the engine of development etc etc
and I accept with them that the bush
societies the
[Music]
um
not London yeah
as you say that the Saint Lucia oh boy
when you rent the land to somebody
at in datarios
anyway so I I I start thinking of this
form of a a production cropping
sharecropping no we're traditional
because you should go into into
Plantation into Trade Union City I must
tell you also that the same time as Cuba
is making its revolution Cuba is
nationalizing Cuba is moving forward and
we were all obviously poor Cuban the
city or city I sit there so we are
seeing that but this is not working in
Haiti you know I mean this is not work
not only this is not working the Cubans
in their efforts no are helping Angola
they are helping
Bolivia Haiti is just around the corner
you said I mean
is it Etc so
so people start to have doubt no and I
start seeing that economic development
is not giving us results and we have to
think in terms of culture and I start
moving with the counter plantation
system looking at it at its importance
and I start discovering the need for
working with Creole for participation of
the people in the development system
no okay so a reaching that point
I would say is a vertical and publish a
book called A I.T and it's Elites no uh
dialogue of death of death people who
cut here
death okay no
and this is the let's say
the the book announcing
heiji and a deconal astrology because it
is at that time that I met my friends of
the colonial thinking no who thought
that my book on
on oppressed culture in fact announces
the whole decolonial thinking because I
was trying to see and this is the
question I was asking myself since in my
the book on oppress culture is my PhD
thesis no so my PhD is saying is asking
what is it that we have done for
ourselves I mean Plantation plant all
sort of thing but we have nothing to do
in Plantation that was imposed on us now
I didn't reach the question like that
but I could have done done it in that
book saying that he
Plantation is not a Caribbean
Institution it is a time when kaiben is
called Plantation America
so I said no no we have something else
Caribbean cannot be English Skype and
Dodge Caravan French cabin Skyway and
period you know I mean there is
something we have done which is not
English when British or Dutch what have
you you said I mean no Spanish for the
so I start looking for what we have done
no this is why I call
a dialogue of this because my the elite
no
no is French the ladies speak French the
laws of French etc etc etc and in one
discussion in okay no I was presenting
the book and somebody said but what
you're saying there is not an elite it
is an oligarchy I say oh God
I should have thought of that because
Elite is very simple if we are 10
shoemakers the best are the Elite of the
shoemakers but if the best do not behave
as giving best shoes they will go down
among the others and other people will
come as Elite this is not the case in
our societies this is a leader of French
speaking people never go down you see me
because they are
and oligarchy you said I mean so I
realize that we do not have any lead we
haven't Elite the voodoo priests and
those are Elites you know I mean but
those who govern the country of French
because are not necessarily relied in
fact they are not Elite they are those
who are holding us down no and therefore
I start now discovering a
the decolonial thought no let me study
what we have done how we have done that
how did the Haitian came to be Haitian
and what make a Haitian different from
the Jamaican from a vincentian or former
Trinidadian I mean because their local
history is different you see when you
take for instance I had the Good Fortune
through the economic commission to work
10 years in Trinidad and I tell the two
in that then you never knew slavery you
are happy people and when you think of
it that's true that religion Trinidad
was spaniel is Spanish Spaniard no
when Haiti started his Revolution no
beginning of 1790s no Spain start
receiving the Planters running away from
Saint domain to such an extent that to
imagine speak the same query that we
speak and we understand each other
because they will come to Trinidad with
their slaves
you said I mean and there are several
example like that and then the Spaniard
and the French Planters no which to
imagine called French Creoles the
refreshment when the slave will
establish Creole as the basic language
of the language of the land together
with Spanish in certain pocket Pockets
speak Spanish French versus Spanish and
creole a bubble Spanish and creole
so soon after the British
the expense seed the island to the
British no and in the Cedar Island the
British has to recognize Iraq knowledge
the internal laws of this land so the
British who are governing and the
Trinidad you know speaking a creole and
French you said I mean the British was
the owner
so I realized at that point in time you
know by 1817 we are 18 through 18 for
when the French start
flowing in the country by 10 years or 20
years after the British stopped the
slave trade
and every time they cut a slim boot in
the Atlantic they come with the slave
and drop them in the so-called slave
captive drop them into Trinidad so the
population of blacks into that you know
I mean are created without slave trades
no so the slave masters know how to take
care of the sleep because they cannot
produce and buy all the slaves they must
make sure that they reproduce themselves
locally not only that soon after 1838
the British stopped a slavery
you say I mean so the the slavery
Haitian I've known for 100 Century with
a slave trade is not what the
trinidadine has known no and when you go
to Trinidad they are happy to happy
going happy looking people they have
never have problems they never fight
they do not even know how to fight
because they never had to fight
you said I mean from the very beginning
the Masters had to make sure that they
have a slave for tomorrow you said I
mean at the beginning then slave we
become
abolish no so I told them you don't know
what sleep is you can imagine that not
only that they start with indentured you
say I mean and flooding the country with
indention so that and whole other
Dynamic and a whole different sets of
okay this experience in Trinidad you
know when they come and give me the
possibility of seeing local history
developing and how we are in our local
history producing a way out of quote
unquote Arab misery you said I mean this
is how I went and see the importance of
the language the importance of the
community the importance of the higlas
because the series of fruits and I must
say also the importance of the yard I
have some strong friends coming American
friends particularly an abroad who wrote
on yards no you know I mean that is
and the way the yard is important in
Jamaica in Kingston she wrote that me
I'm seeing the word in the countryside
then you go to Dominica there are
several studies in Dominica and Saint
Lucia on the family poverty system
all those are institutions that archive
in it's not that you don't have family
poverty system in France but it does not
characterize the land in your system
while in our countries it is the basis
of lentenuous system and the work I have
used in Dominica shows that those who
who has learned in the lentenia system
produce more than those who have learned
in the situation so this is how I end up
in my my why that's my why no because I
reached a point where I can explain to
myself what they call poverty no
and why we are quite happy in that
poverty if you want to see it that way
now we will be unhappy in the court in
the city because in the city we are not
able to reproduce the yard properly to
have our resources to reproduce it
so I guess my question is
so Creole languages are like very
important to the Caribbean Community but
we like refer to English Creole as
broken English where you promote French
over Asian Creole so my question is like
what do you think will happen to our
communities if we keep projecting
they're real I love this question if you
keep projecting projecting rejecting
yeah
okay but first of all
let me say that
I have an improvement Theory and I'm
trying to convince some a linguists to
work on it because I cannot but the the
info I should already they don't pay
attention
forget about the English school and
French Creole because they are
identified they exist they are bodies
they are their their syntaxes they are
their vocabulary they have their word
for instance I don't go make I see you
you know I mean this exist they are
there to see
my problems start when I speak with the
Puerto Ricans and the Dominicans they
speak Spanish
they speak the an imperial language
yet I'm pretty sure that this Imperial
language carry a historical tradition
that depart from the caste and Native
Spanish
yes yes you said I mean and they must
have concept like we have like whites
which is not white that's black which is
not black like which I mean ni this is
what I call linguistic archeology I want
somebody to tell me what is the Puerto
Rican or the Dominican or the Cuban you
know our producing
yeah I mean that Define them and make
them different from the
Imperial from the Castilian you said I
mean okay now in our case no
the problem basic problem and this is a
problem with France and the French
UNESCO its own
they have to justify their existence no
they come with the idea of universality
you know I mean the universal
civilization Universal God knows what
and they want to destroy all diversity
you said I mean and our Elite buy into
that Universal things you said I mean
but and they will tell you for instance
if the Haitians feel cruel they will be
isolated I say let's go quiet Haiti has
now 8 to 12 million
when I visited Curacao they had 90
million 90 yes
one day I was living in Trinidad and I
wanted you know through that very Street
quite British and you cannot buy
everything IBM everything is control so
I'm going to curasa which is a
commercial place I have to buy something
for my BM but I don't know I'll be
amazing so I come on the street I saw
fellow Wellness he should know I asked
where is IBM he said no no I don't know
ask that lady and the lady is selling
fruits
so I tell the lady sorry excuse me where
is IBM
in what language do you want the
information
she speaks
but she speak Dutch she speak English
she speak French it's because sort of
language I could choose the language to
receive my information because in
Curacao as he would say papa mentota by
school they teach papiamento in the
schools you know I mean and the people
speaking papiamento can speak he learn
and speak because of the commercial any
language you want I mean they are not
isolated by parliamento but I mean to
help them to to be linked with the
others you said I mean no so if we
manage and control our local languages
Etc and we can find out what is the
specificity of our language together we
do that we learn to appreciate our
language to appreciate their language
and to appreciate us who have invented a
way of respecting everybody yeah you
said I mean so to my mind this is the
point and this is uh
not a theory but I don't know how to
call it they are venon they are putting
down or if H is prescribed they will be
isolated aren't we isolated now
and since when do we speak French
in France just learn how to speak French
but just learn it's 100 years I mean
French is a is a I don't know for
English is worse they told me French is
the language of the administration in of
Paris and French was imposed on the on
the provinces of France to strengthen
the central power
no and it remains
I mean the
Eugene November present that he only in
his book
no it's really important because French
is not a country that come from all
French people no no because French was a
country of peasants and the plantation
is the first capitalist rational uh
[Music]
economic
concern no this is why when you have
English in Jamaica you have clearly
Jamaicans people English period all
Jamaicans while in France you leave one
Village you go to another one you cannot
understand what they are saying because
they have a small
microclimate micro Village without the
connection that would give you in the
end into a comprehension you said I mean
this is a fact and when they say Haiti
and then well let's say hate to speak
French
from Colonial time up to now please
please no
no now it's they find that insolent and
insulted that in some Canadian and
French University they request the
Haitian to present a kind of truffle
examination
prove that this French and this is the
fact that I teach at University now is
University student who really cannot
express
can represent any say improper French
yeah
it's also like interesting on top about
how they keep that structure in like
French Canada despite despite even
French Canadians being treated as lesser
and yes the French eyes because they
they call Canadian French
disgusting French like they call it
lesser French so it's funny how even in
Canada where it's like their French is
deemed lesser they still keep yes
because they are the English also
because they have the English they think
is better yeah I mean
so this is this is really really good so
we've had an amazing set of questions
and I wanted to follow up on jazara's
question
um
and and here I want to go back to the
UNESCO issue because we we heard this
very eloquent plea from uh
on what grounds are you classifying
Korean languages as lesser languages
they are languages that's it but your
work one thing which I love about joke
is that you show the the beauty and
power of Haitian Creole you show the
richness
of the of the vocabulary and how the
vocabulary can tell us so much about our
history and and those facts that you put
out so so beautifully words like Ras
[Music]
blush you should do that that all these
words for them to have evolved at
semantics in fact that's yet another
argument against the idea that Creoles
evolved from Pigeon because you see a
pigeon is supposed to be like like
a like an empty void of language from
which you create a new language and your
algorithm is that no look at all this
richness in the language you see so I I
so I want to stress that because often
we still find in various circles the
notion that curios evolve from pigeons
and yet you've given us through history
yet another set of arguments against
that view you see and one thing which I
wanted to ask you as well is
so in your introduction to your lecture
on um on Monday you were introduced as a
as a historical sociologist right and
but when I speak to you I often speak to
you as a linguist you see what what you
tell me about Creole about our national
language
you share all these data that I as a
language can so deeply appreciate you
see so so I want to ask you so why do
you why are you being called
ethical sociologists when in fact
so much of your work is linguistic and
and here actually I'm thinking it's
Advocates right I don't want to say that
you know you should be one of the other
I don't know I just want to hear you
talk about the the role that Linguistics
and language make it even more explicit
how it plays into your your work as a
sociologist and as a historian because I
love it and I and I think that you in a
way you give us a model of how the human
Sciences can really operate together to
discover a Humanity a common Humanity so
that's you know so I want to praise you
for that but I want you to to say
something more about it let me see that
the
this idea
comes from the group of friends with
whom I
unite every every year
the the Maya Laguna is the colonial
School
no it's uh it's a
summer school we have every year during
three weeks or for three weeks no in
Holland organized by the University of
Utrecht and the Duke University is a
center with Walter Mineola now and they
do not believe in disciplines you know
this group is formed by philosophers
historians economists sociologists
artists
of performers and all sorts of artists
and we are thinking and and oh I forgot
Catherine she's a sociologist and
activist
but anyway and this group no they do not
even speak of University they speak of
pluriversity you know I mean I mean this
is we have to save the plurality we have
to save our diversity because this is
what I was saying on the universality
that French and the capitalist system
what because they want one universal
civilization God knows what no no no no
is we will probably have that Universal
thing I won't be there to look at it but
when we all in our diversity we
contribute now we are negotiating maybe
a university for the time being is
privacy so therefore you raise the
question
how is Haiti so quote-unquote poor
so I say God word hold on what is hate
well the Haitians what is a Haitian
no foreign
how come
they become Haitians or whatever other
countries you have no and you see what
are the institutions and the process and
local history become the heart of the
your Affliction local history I mean by
local history it's not the local history
offer in the archives because in the
arcade you will find the local history
of those who wonder why you say I mean
so you have to see you people who is
speaking because
to whom are you speaking you are
speaking to you people you have to
explain to them what is it that they
have done themselves this is why I
cannot accept that the Caribbean
will be a British guy band french guy
band Spanish Caribbean come on where is
the Caribbean therefore I mean are we
British are we French are we no no no no
we are Caribbean and we have made
certain number of things but not because
we are kind when we are all stimulus we
have also a variety in that no and this
is for instance the real problem when
they say we are blacks we are blacks
okay black is an invention of the
colonial world no of the modern Colonial
one the modern Colonial world one us all
of us to be the same so we can do
whatever they want so for instance the
richest black swim on our black will
teach the other black no no no no no no
no we all of our have our values we all
respect ourselves and we want to listen
to you you want you to listen to us no
and out of these variety of blacks if
you were to call them blacks I don't
call them black but that's okay no
etc etc and I think this this is
something you have
while you're conquering your sovereignty
for instance as far as I'm concerned
Haiti's 19 1791
was able to join together people from
different nations of Africa and create
Haiti no but when you reach for instance
a
2010 2011 in the U.S you see all the
oppress of the U.S come and see black
lives matters
you see I mean and when you look at
those who are saying that you have to
make an effort to find all the blacks
you find all the people that are the
most exploited is the black but you buy
all sort of Latins all sorts of
Americans all sort of whites who have
been exploited in their blacks life
matters you know I mean any this respect
for the life of the oppressed become
effective if you can impose that on the
dominant system
I think many things are going to change
in fact what you have is the end of an
era
you know I mean an era that is the era
where life does not matter period you
know I mean there is a wonderful
movie that just come out don't look up I
don't know if you see I know that's a
wonderful life does not matter simply
not you know I mean they have to make
more money it's a nice move it's sad
really uh
it's sad but it's comical I mean it's
cynic I don't know more than suck it's
cynical no more than well you said I
mean this is the point we are saying
black lives matters we are saying life
matters period the life of the Earth the
life of we every every life matters and
if you can reach that point you stop
that system who defined as a producer of
inequality
you mean this is the point because black
is simply an element of inequality you
can imagine that fellow made a mistake
and he called all those indigenous
people all those Indians but that his
mistake why should I carry that mistake
today when I know it's a mistake this is
worse you know I mean this is the
problem no how in doing that we call
East Indian a series well why should I
say East Indian and we are supposed to
be West Indians a set of mistakes eh
because West Indian originally you know
it ends no
the Philippines
everything that was from the West Was
West Indians from us America way down to
Philippine that was the West Indian I
mean this mistake I don't have to carry
it in the 21st century you said I mean
so a okay so it's 2 57 so we should take
up closing we actually got married in um
yes there's no idea it's like how do we
have these conversations oh how do we
have these conversations outside of the
classroom and like if black and race is
a social constant I don't get you come
again oh like how do we have these types
of conversations outside of the
classroom because we are having it and
it's like a difficult conversation and
also like if black and race are a social
construct then what are we supposed to
identify with especially like in a
country where you know Americans really
like to categorize things so it's like
what do we do like for me I struggle I
struggle a lot to say what I am like I
am Dominican I am Caribbean but like in
the US they do focus a lot on like race
so it's like what are we supposed to no
I I cannot tell you what I can tell you
is that it's a matter of local history
in Haiti we end up creating the Haitians
in Jamaica we end up reaching the
Jamaicans in Haiti or in Jamaica or in
any country of the Caribbean blacks are
the majority
no then I will tell you about the
Dominican Republic is something that I
am the only one to accept not the
Dominicans not the Haitians Make Me
Remember that you know
the problem is local history blacks in
the U.S no are one out of ten
in Haiti we are 99 out of 100. or in
most Caribbean countries so blacks is
what exists so you cannot say why one
day I told a friend in Haiti you say
black is beautiful you know what they're
going to tell you is there anything else
[Laughter]
but it's not to be beautiful
I mean okay so
it's to another term you have to if you
need to have to close Okay Town yes
um
if
so no I haven't finished me
all right okay okay let me try to do me
so I think this is where the local
history I can understand the U.S
African-American ending up yeah it
identifying himself as black because
this is what he unite them that hell
their local history that is not our
local history you said I mean and I can
tell you I suffer for that but because I
went one day and see something about
black Festival deity blacks that's not
an issue oh boy imagine okay that's one
thing you see so the problem is to see
how black appears in a given context now
for my Dominican Republic problems I
thought the Dominican Republic say black
flat in Haiti I'm not black I'm in a
dark Indian yeah yes not the black
obviously this is
scandalous for those who are not
Dominican public exception because I say
listen go to Dominica the island of
Dominica an island which have received a
large part of land as a reserve where
the Americans or the
Dominicans leaves no and they reproduce
themselves in their society since
Colonial time
men who make a kid with I mean they are
Indians they are not trying to Skype
women who have a an
offering with black
woman no the kid is amerindian is
carried women
of the Caribs who make a kid with a
black outside the kid is black
so you can imagine you cannot
distinguish
between black and and because if you're
living in the cave among the Caribbean
no and if etc etc okay if you are in
Dominican Republic you are Latino or you
are a slave brought by Christopher
Columbus no and you get in maroonas you
go and you are received in a in an
Indian a Indian a dino
Community you have a kid the kid is
going to be black
is to be Tino period he's not black no
matter how the color is and so on and so
forth now if you are receiving blacks in
Haiti
no and they will come in the Dr they are
blacks
because they are not born in an Indian
Society
you see what I mean so I find normal
that the Indians say the Haitians are
black they're under black
you know I mean they are Indians dark
Indians but they are Indians because
this is the population now Christopher
Christopher Columbus ah yeah that's a
good sleep because Raphael you need
that to sleep we'll use that no to make
of the black something different and to
discriminate against the Haitians and
also to discriminate against the black
Dominican Dominicans no because it's
situ Etc but I am not supposed to carry
the sin of Christ away Mr Rafael
University the same way I don't want to
carry the sin of a of a
of Columbus no so I have to acknowledge
the normal Dominican is right he blocks
his Haitian
he's not that well but nobody accept
that yeah
um but it's it's a whole discussion that
there's no time to get into that in
Haiti there is colorism right like if
that's mixed with class so there's that
famous saying of a cow that reach a rich
black is a mulatto and a permulato is
black right no no no no providing he
knows how to win right exactly exactly
exactly so so anyway so that's it we
have no time for that so let's let's be
extremely extremely thankful
flowers to Professor
to you for your questions
thank you